today
we decided to do a post show live where
we talk about the show
and you know
talk about you guys have youtube
channels yeah yeah
so i'm justin mark i'm a dating coach uh
i teach dating and lifestyle development
and uh picking up girls on youtube and
it's cool because everything's
documented it's pretty much documenting
my lifestyle of me picking up girls and
teaching guys how to do that
right on my name is luis mercado i'm a
youtuber a lot of people know me from to
catch a cheater i also started a kids
channel as of recently prior to that i
was really big into psychology i used to
be a body language coach
i've done a lot of things in sales for a
long time 34 years old and we're
traveling europe right now so i'm very
excited to be back on this extended
version of the podcast that's so cool
how to catch a cheater that is i have so
many questions but jess you wanna you
wanna introduce you haven't been on in a
minute i haven't been on here in a while
she's been here though i know i've been
in here um which camera looking at how
are you how do you like in the past you
know it's all right you know
it's a it could have been better but no
i'm playing i love it it's great here
but um
hey guys i'm jess um you guys know me
from just multiple episodes on just
pearly things channel it's great to be
back on camera for a bit for this post
show
chat
um
i don't know who i am
uh
i don't know what i'm a little
discombobulated from the last dress are
you a woman
yeah i'm a woman i'm i'm pearl right now
um yeah sara garvey you already know me
um i just want to kind of get into this
like
post
like you know like post thing so i want
to i want to hear what you guys really
have got to say so too yeah i mean well
there were a lot of people in the room i
didn't want to interrupt or overtake the
podcast i was just kind of letting
everyone speak their mind but you know
one thing that was early on with the
girl with the red hair was talking about
was the um
you know well don't you think that men
shouldn't judge women who've slept with
a thousand women men and all this and
it's like it's interesting the the
philosophy that she's trying to take on
it's like hey listen like your choices
have consequences people are going to
make assessments that's what we do as
humans we meet people we make an
assessment whether this is a positive or
negative person right someone we want to
involve in our life or not i mean that
is what we do if i meet someone and they
have a history of being like a child
predator right like i'm sorry bro i'm
gonna make a judgment about it a map
yeah so like to say well we should be
more empathetic i'm sorry no
like i'm as a human i have empathy that
you're mentally ill and you have this
issue but that doesn't mean i need to
correct my life to adjust for you
you know and she's saying well the world
should be more understanding
it's like well now it's all about you
isn't it so this is just your
narcissistic self yeah it's narcissism
she's just narcissistic in her thoughts
i wish you said that you two just go
just go guys yeah tell me tell me
you know what i didn't want to like
point fingers or attack this dude but
this this there was a man on the show
who literally said he's okay with his
wife getting [ __ ] by other men
that is like because i'm like thinking
i'm like you know it's 20 22. don't
judge you know keep an open mind i'm
like absolutely not
absolutely no chance
right it's just that's absolutely it's
unacceptable right and so like a man
who's okay with that it's like where is
that coming from it's coming from deep
some deeper trauma it's coming from like
horrible upbringing and i mean he said
himself it's like you know he's venting
and complaining about like his
upbringing and he's like i turned out
fine but it's like well did you because
like
you're okay with other dudes hooking up
with your [ __ ] your girl yeah you
know and that's [ __ ] man like it's not
okay right is he did he say that he's
also hooking up with other women yeah
but come on what girl is sleeping with
them all he's basically saying is the
only way i get to keep this girl is by
allowing her to [ __ ] other men that's
all it is because if he had by choice
she would not [ __ ] any other man
but he has that's the only way you can
get her so he's okay with it
okay with it
you know what i mean that's interesting
and we know as men if if our woman was
[ __ ] someone else he'd be like all
right cool that's where you want to be
go for it goodbye it would never happen
i just think girls have one foot out the
door when they're doing that they're
just trying to see what they can get i
don't even think she has a foot in the
door if she's doing that and i think
she's just out the door i'm sorry would
you really like a guy you don't you
don't want to do that yeah and that's
why i asked that girl too and she's just
trying to be argumentative i'm like
let's be real
let's be real like if you loved this man
and respected that man and that like you
just craved this man because he's a
masculine man that's presented himself
in such a way you wouldn't have any
desire to go out and [ __ ] other men
you know it's just period
and if she does she probably has mental
there'd be some type of mental issues
going on there because it's
psychological issue right yeah and
stemming from somewhere and that's
that's the thing like i think a lot of
times girls will argue that men and
women are the same when like girls
have become more masculine like they're
sleeping around like guys but i'm like
you didn't start off like that there's
no way if i when i talk to you if you
were 14 15 16 and they'd be starting
early let's say let's say 13 14. like
that you didn't want to get married and
have kids in a family
like i'm sorry you did not start off
like that she's like well someone sold
you on that idea and it's like and
someone's selling you on this idea and
like look at the look at what's
what's becoming the outcome of that of
that thinking that philosophy that
you're trying to adapt of i can sleep
with a hundred men and have meaningless
sex and it's not gonna mean anything
it's like you're someone's selling you
on that idea and there's probably a
bigger purpose for it i don't wanna get
into conspiracies
but um no tell it what's your conspiracy
uh that's a longer conversation
i was not yeah
it's a bigger conversation but the thing
is this
i think girls even intrinsically know
that in some way their value is attached
to their body count right which is why
it's just i mean tell me if i'm wrong
when you see girls being catty with each
other or they hate a girl what's the
first thing they call her she's a [ __ ]
she's a slow
right oh no you don't want to talk to
her she's a hoe they're trying to
you know separate her from the group
by saying you know she sleeps around
it's like they know intrinsically that
there is value attached to that so to
pretend there's not it's like look i'm
very open-minded about things and i'm
not i'm very non-judgmental like that
guy wants to live his life i'm cool bro
like that's totally fine i don't
whatever yeah not much
yeah you know but um
yeah she's it's just there's this
movement where they're selling her on
this life
and i ultimately i believe it's going to
lead to a depressing life especially in
the second half of uh yeah your life so
one of my buddies he has a sister who
works in a psych ward and he found that
there's a lot of women who are you know
in their 40s and 50s coming in and
they're they're having like manic
episodes because you know they're older
now they didn't have families they
didn't have kids
and
the issue there is it's because they
were in their 20s and 30s sleeping
around yeah right and you know they got
older they didn't develop their like
character in their personality they
didn't you know nurture the
relationships they are single now
they're older and it's like
i feel like women biologically you're
like pretty much you want to have kids
most women want to have children or have
a family or something like at least 80
women want to have that and when you're
not having that it's like you now have a
completely unfulfilled desire right
meanwhile like i could just hook up with
tons of girls until i'm 57 and i could
find a cute 21 year old girl from
colombia and like settle down with her
and have a family if i choose to in my
60s no you couldn't justin
[Music]
90 day fiance
like we're just talking hypothetically
though right because like biologically
men can continue having sex their whole
life and continue producing offspring
women can't right
and so that's the issue there
so like
do you think that it's a mental
do you think that it affects women's
mental health then yeah of course
that's the older they get well it's
linked to higher rates of depression
women that sleep around more yeah and
like they're on antidepressants where
there's a bunch of stats that go with it
yeah so like when people ask me a lot of
times people ask me i had a conversation
with us about another girl not too long
ago where like one of the first things
she was mentioning was if it body count
matters
and it's like well
like yes and no
like
i care more about their mental state and
i know that women that are very
promiscuous that sleep around a lot
they're not going to live in an
emotionally healthy place where i'd want
to be around this girl and i don't judge
her i have a sister i have a lot of
women in my life that i know and i care
about
i just wouldn't date them because they
don't make for good partners in
long-term partner thinking
well
what do you think about are you familiar
with rolo tomasi's work
what do you think about um he has an
idea it's not about the number it's like
the number of alphas basically
i don't know i i've never really well he
he'll always say like if a girl slept
with five guys and one of them was jason
i don't even know who jason mamoa is
like i genuinely don't know who that is
yeah aquaman like a superhero i don't
know but apparently he's very good
looking he's a big joke
like that's that's worse than like 20 if
they're like average half a widow me
yeah i'd probably agree would you agree
with that or disagree yeah of course
definitely yeah i feel bad for any girl
that's how to like try dating after me
because they just know they're not going
to get quite as good dang that's a flesh
no but you know do you know what's so
funny i i hate you because i kind of
feel like i'm women's alpha widow yeah
do you know what i mean
and it's not like
it's not like a i don't know it's not
like an arrogant thing it's because you
know what how you've experienced women
do you get what i'm saying so when you
say that i i totally get you bro
i i really do i totally i understand
like a lot of guys know that they are
the alpha widow
and when you say that yeah i'm like the
jason mo more like
yeah
i'm gonna leave it at that i'm gonna
leave it
again and i don't think that you know
the alpha widow concept is even like a
it's not like a physical thing i think
it's a psychological thing it's like the
way you make her feel emotionally
exactly right because uh i mean like
this is a really interesting concept but
i noticed like a lot of women they can
just break up the boyfriend like that
right right but when they break up the
boyfriend they're really in love with
and they see a future with they keep
coming back not only just keep coming
back but it's like once the
relationship's really over
um i actually do you remember when i was
out with you in l.a three years ago
2019. we're in the middle of hollywood
and we're just like picking up girls bar
hopping whatever my ex-girlfriend calls
me we're in the middle of the street
i've talked to her in six months and
she's like crying telling me she was
like addicted to xanax and it's like
when we were dating she wasn't drinking
she was doing drugs right and it's like
just the thought of you know losing such
a deep intimate relationship
sorry it's a
pill it's like a
sleeping
antidepressant no it's um it's used for
like stuff yeah off of it like rappers
taking [ __ ] they got high and stuff oh
okay so
yeah
it's like a painkiller like a very
strong painkiller okay and uh it makes
you sleep and stuff but it's crazy
because like when you have that like
deep because like i think the cause of
being alpha is completely psychological
phenomenon where the man is just
completely
psychologically dominant
right over
psychologically dominant yeah i don't
think it's not a physical thing i think
it's i think it's a psychological thing
and it's an emotional place you're
coming from and that's what uh drives a
lot of alpha males to like make a lot of
money uh you know crushing business be
entrepreneurial uh be natural leaders uh
and be really good with women right and
i also think a lot of men can develop
themselves into being an alpha
male
through deep deep work and character
development right but once you become
that guy you become literally addictive
and so it's extremely painful to lose a
guy like that do you know what it's so
funny i don't think that's alpha i think
it's sigma
i think
i think the sigma male is something that
it's not spoken about more so than the
alpha are we going through the greeks
yeah because yeah because
like okay so if you if you were to
research the sigma male right um
the sigma male
in
in dominant terms the same as the alpha
but the sigma male displays
characteristics
that are more elusive than the alpha
and i think women get attracted to men
that are more elusive
what does that mean that word elusive
okay so
if a man walks into a room and he's like
i'm the [ __ ] man low status
right i'm the man but the thing is not
only is he the man he could be the man
right
but he's kind of brash with it
but there is a certain male within that
room
that displays the same type of energy
that just kind of floats right and it
gets a woman's attention like
who's that like
who because he's not brash and he's not
telling people that he's actually
the man
but there's something within the woman
that knows he is the man he just exudes
it he exudes it do you know what i mean
more so than tells people that he is it
and i think if you look at if you if
people research
the sigma male and the alpha male
it will become more clear and i think a
lot of the time
that i would class andrew tate as people
say he's alpha i would say the sigma
knowing what i know
it's just me personally
and i think the sigma male is something
that has not been um explored enough
that's just me personally
because because there's that elusiveness
to amanda there's that mysterious thing
to a man that women that attracts women
also
yeah i mean yeah i think any guy that
has to say something
takes away from you know like if a guy
has to say oh i'm rich well then it's
like
you sound insecure to have to say that
like right why do you care about their
opinion in the first place that man is
i'm the king
don't say you're the king a king is kind
of self-evident
well you know it's crazy so i grew up my
dad's like a top half a percent earner
and i'm just saying this for context not
to like brag but i know
a lot of like really wealthy people and
it's never the people you'd expect right
like i know someone worth
50 to 100 million money doesn't make you
i don't think they they literally drive
the same car for 20 years they're so
cheap i like
i'm like if i had that much money i
would spend some of it i swear
it was a waste
but it's like never the people you'd
expect
and it's like it's like they have a
quiet confidence about them because they
never feel the need to like show off
sorry culture who's a sigma and who is
like the like the the um the possible of
a sigma
um john wick
have you seen john wick yeah thank you
keanu reeves
that [ __ ] there's a mystery are
you saying like keanu reeves or johnny
no john wick the actual character oh
okay that is a
mystery to the guy
right that woman like who is this guy
but when it's time to get [ __ ] done that
[ __ ] gets [ __ ] done
however
he's still mysterious
whereas an alpha
would be someone who is more so
in the forefront that you can see as an
alpha and i think the sigma male like
john wick
would challenge
a quote unquote alpha male and women
will be like who
who's that guy
more so than
somebody who's brash and just that
almond alpha and i think
that guy is the
is the guy that a lot of a lot of women
are attracted to over the alpha that's
just me but
researching
whatever that
like that as well it's that there's this
demeanor of like mystery yes that women
can't because like i'm again i'm a
dating coach i love breaking down the
archetypes
of guys like that it's just like because
you're not giving it all away it makes
someone extremely curious and that
becomes extremely addictive yes right
and uh yeah cause i mean think about
matt like our buddy matt for example uh
super mysterious and like girls just
can't figure him out
and he doesn't say a lot he doesn't
speak a lot but there's this like
underlying like just savage
presence that he has
and uh it's and it's a confidence yeah
exactly oh tell me okay tell me why i
like the guys i like
so i find there's two types of guys i
date okay
i either date one that's like also an
entertainer and like funny too so we're
both we kind of like bounce off each
other and so the other one just like
doesn't talk and laughs at my jokes
those are the two types of guys i date
i okay so personally i think you you
demonstrate a lot of like very empowered
leadership qualities
and i feel like you're very like
emotionally dominant for for a woman
right yeah and
because of that i think you're gonna
like even though you say you'd like a
guy because in our in our podcast uh we
just did you said that you'd love to
have a guy who leads a relationship but
when you said that i was really thinking
i don't think you're that's gonna be a
common thing that you're going to find
in relationships because i mean look at
you're an entrepreneur you're you have a
large audience you're like somebody's
very vocal and whatnot and it makes
sense that
you're naturally going to find someone
who balances that out so someone who's
kind of more reacting to you you know
you know what's interesting more like a
blueprint even even with the
entrepreneur stuff i have men make
decisions for really actually like they
make decisions for everything okay so
like i i go to my dad for every decision
i make and it's it's funny because and i
even got a manager because i didn't want
to make decisions so it's kind of funny
you say that because i feel like it's
like i hate making decisions so there's
like different styles of relationships
right there's like you know you can
your father can fill that need
of
the emotional
uh experience you're trying to have from
a man yeah and then you can just have a
guy who makes you fulfilled you know
psychologically in the relationship like
the relationship dynamic
uh experience that you wanna have oh
interesting yeah i was just about like
why do i like why are we attracted to
because it's like you're also
attracted to stoicism and so i think
that's one thing i like but at the same
time like i've dated guys that are kind
of the opposite like one's funny one's
stoic
well
stoicism is like being unreactive and i
think guys who are unreactive in general
mm-hmm
it's just a very attractive
characteristic right a man who's like
very reactive and emotional is gonna
make the best you know logical decisions
uh but then also guys who are like funny
and goofy
uh you know keeps things interesting
keeps things like
they don't take themselves too seriously
and i think a lot of guys who are
you know funny and can make fun of
themselves or have a lot of humor that's
it that's a good indicator of high
status somebody's high status oh
interesting because somebody's high
status typically is like everything's
everything's fine like your your life is
in control like everything's cool and uh
because you
now feel like relaxed you can just like
let loose
and you know be comfortable with
yourself
interesting
so i have a question about being a
dating coach well actually my first
question okay i have a lot of questions
you guys are going to continue
how do you guys know each other
uh justin i got in touch on instagram we
were supposed to shoot a video like four
years ago
we ended up meeting up we never shot the
video but we became good friends because
we were just kind of interested in the
same things
and we kind of connected and then he
lives in toronto i live in la so for the
most part we've only hung out when we've
traveled
oh so you guys are yeah barcelona africa
colombia and now this europe trip
yeah but it's crazy because we spent a
lot of time together and when we're
traveling together we're pretty much
living together so we've become like
really close and also we see things very
similarly yeah it's really interesting
so
what has it been like being a dating
coach like you kind of get to see the
side of men that women don't get done
i've seen it a little bit because i i
was telling you i went to that pickup
artist like boot camp
but i'm curious like what do you see
that women don't see i mean you you
really get to see like the absolute best
and worst of guys because you can see
guys who are deeply deeply insecure
using sex and validation for women to
kind of like kill themselves when truth
is they need therapy or like meditation
or need to like just
go do some soul searching right then you
also get like guys who are just deeply
miserable and borderline suicide like i
had a client who is let me call me he
told me he's uh literally suicidal and i
asked him i'm like well do you think if
you had a threesome to hop long girls
tonight you'd be suicidal he's like
definitely not
like well there's your [ __ ] answer
right he's like he's 35 years old and
he's a virgin right he makes six figures
he's 35 years old and has no friends no
women in his life out of whatsoever so
he's absolutely just like depressed and
miserable what was his job
uh he works as a computer programmer
okay
and so the first night i bring him to a
nightclub
right he's making all the girl right
this girl clearly likes him but now
it's like girls are clearly attractive
he's good looking he dresses very
elegantly
but
the thing is he just doesn't know what
to say
how to lead how to you know lead the
social interaction forward into a place
of like intimacy and
you know
fun
and uh so he's just completely
unattractive in his behavior like again
women are they're not attracted to your
aesthetic they're i mean that's part of
it that gets your foot in the door right
women before they decide to sleep with
you they're looking at the way you make
them feel the way looking at you know
who you are as a person
your
your vibe your overall demeanor your
body language all these other factors
right
and so when you don't have that it
doesn't matter how good looking or how
well dressed you are what kind of
amazing job you have you know you're
just not going to get the results you
want to get
so
how has
because okay
this is what i've heard from like being
like a like would you say you're a
pickup artist like dating coach type
they say on one end like it's better
because you get late all the time like
but you also see like the negative side
of women so you're the guy that the girl
cheats with you're the guy oh you're the
guy that like the girl said oh i've only
slept with three people and then she
screws you two hours like
you're the guy that sees and i was gonna
ask this kind of ties to you too because
you run the channel how to catch a
cheater so you you also have seen like
the worst sides of human nature
has that changed your perspective on
women negatively
at all i wouldn't say negatively for me
i would just say i understand what
reality is yeah so i'm not nothing will
throw me off at this point in my life
like i'm not phased by much of anything
i just i understand human behavior
and i understand that um
i understand why women cheat and why
you know
these things happen
i'm just understanding because i just
i've seen it so much
um as weird as it is when i ran that
channel because i don't really do it too
much anymore but when i was doing to
catch a cheater there were tons of girls
that were reaching out to me to test
their boyfriend and they'd end up
cheating on their boyfriend with me
wow
it's crazy but see their boyfriend can't
comment like if they were to get caught
talking to me it's like well i was just
talking to him because i was gonna put
you to the test so they try to have
their escape route
then in their mind they're looking at me
like i truly like to look at myself as
just a regular guy
um
but they look at me in a way like oh my
god he has three million followers uh
he's funny he's cocky he's in shape
you know and then like i'm on this show
so like in their mind they're thinking
this guy's
of um they're just placing me at a
higher caliber than their boyfriend like
a celebrity status kind of yeah exactly
so then when they meet me and i was
telling justin i was like man it's crazy
how many times i'd meet girls they'd be
shaking when they'd meet me and i was
like it's [ __ ] nuts bro like they're
just you know they're like nervous to
meet me and i'll come here let's give
him a hug
like to calm him down but they're just
like and i already know it's over like i
feel sorry for their boyfriend
um wait wait wait wait can i
rewind
okay
questions so
she would meet up with you to get to
test her boyfriend yeah and would you do
the test
sometimes you know okay so so let's
let's just i just want to like how would
this work so what type of test would you
do think of one example where you hooked
up with her what tests did you do they
wouldn't even well we wouldn't if we
hooked up we wouldn't test her boyfriend
it was just
oh did you ever like test the boyfriend
and hook up with them
no
no okay okay
so
they would meet with you to test their
boyfriend like they would come to your
apartment yeah or they'd break up with
them the weekend before and then they'd
come see me and they get back together a
week later
because you know like they people break
up over the weekend like that's what
they're doing these guys are so clueless
when they get when they break up with
their girlfriend because they're trying
to justify why they're doing what
they're doing so they'll start a fight
even if it's at a subconscious level
they start a fight messaged me hey you
know we got into fighting he's being a
dick and whatever yadda yadda like oh we
should hang out then you know [ __ ] him
you know then we hang out then we hook
up and then i find out like two weeks
later i'm blocked like what the [ __ ] i
go my other account i see oh she's back
together with him you know
and it's just it's crazy that like i
don't judge women for it i'm just aware
that these things happen
and um
you know so so there's just saying
attraction's not a choice right
and you know in the pickup artist
community where you're learning how to
like talk to women
you realize that like women can't even
help if they're attracted to a man it
doesn't necessarily mean they're going
to act on it right but the crazy thing
is like in a situation like that with
luis it's like
the women are thinking okay well i've
got this celebrity influencer youtube
guy and he's on camera he's being funny
he's confident he's kind of cocky a
little bit like you know arrogant and
all these things are very attractive
behavioral cues so they can't even help
but be attracted to him right and so a
lot of like the behavior is subconscious
right i even noticed that with like a
lot of my coaching clients or even just
like myself when like i would i would
meet a lot of women hook up with them
and then find out after they have a
boyfriend and yeah there was definitely
a time where it just made me super jaded
because i was just like thinking every
girl cheats you know because
we're living in a world where just like
you only
it's not that i'm getting cheated on
it's just i see
every girl that hangs around me ends up
cheating on their [ __ ] boyfriend and
it you know at some point i had to kind
of realize like
it's
it's not
them it's actually the world i live in
and uh because i actually i have a
girlfriend right now and i it doesn't
cross my mind that you'd like cheat you
know
that was actually my question if if it
ever made you like more suspicious of
girls you dated because in my head like
i don't know how it couldn't
when you when you see like all the worst
parts of human nature not just also a
woman so it would affect you differently
what do you mean what do you i would
think like the guy would be worse
because like for us
you know like dudes can screw anything
so
you know but like as a guy
like i don't know if you saw firsthand
all the [ __ ] that girls do
so i would say no because i'm also very
calibrated on reading people okay so and
let's be real like you know what you're
getting when you meet a guy
if you're really being honest with
yourself when you meet a guy you start
hanging out with them one or two dates
you know what kind of guy you're getting
it's no different for a guy you can be
in denial but the same girl that was
putting your titties and ass out on the
instagram for everyone to see and then
you're confused why she's being
promiscuous it's like bro what do you
think you're getting
so like you knew what you were getting
when you started talking to her so now
you're surprised
well
i you don't think girls can hide it
though they can yeah but they can but
they're the best at hiding it that's
yeah they're better than men they're
better than men because like this is
this is a story i've told this story so
many times on my podcast i'm gonna do it
again you can't stop me
like there's a girl i played um
yeah i'm getting too big i gotta stop
being so specific um
a sport with in college um
and basically
um she she slept with a guy her freshman
year and was like dating him like a
month but he was like
he's kind of a loser but like a good
looking loser you know what i mean
anyways he cheats on her they break up
whatever she's dating a new guy four
years later
and he buys her house she's living with
him in the house and then like i was at
a party
and i saw her walk out of the bathroom
with the guy from freshman year and yeah
the next dude comes to the party an hour
later like so she literally and i'm like
and i'm telling you this girl you would
you would never know i i you would never
guess what i was like your typical i
wouldn't know if i'm dating the girl i
would know yeah yeah i'm telling you
this would not get behind me so you feel
like because you you you've experienced
it so much that you could tell easy even
before the show
i would know
just because i've spent so much time
studying human psychology and human
behavior
that i would just know what kind of girl
i'm getting you know um
is it possible that maybe it happens
maybe i mean we've landed on the moon
i'm sure many things are possible so
yeah i guess it could but i'm so
calibrated that it just it's it's not
gonna happen there's actually experience
i had a couple weeks ago
probably about three weeks ago where i
actually met a girl's boyfriend
and then i hooked up with her a few days
later and like the guy was i know it was
bad i felt guilty but she was a smoke
show why do you feel guilty uh i feel a
little bit guilty but like in my head
it's just like cuck or be cupped i mean
i rather i'd rather be on one end than
the other right like i don't be like the
guy from the the show we just did right
and so
this
like
is obviously getting her boyfriend
anyway she's coming to hang out with me
and my friends anyway she apologized
that her boyfriend like supposedly show
up because um she she came to my house
and then i guess he had her location
turned on so he ended up showing up to
my house i invited him in i i pretty
much told him like like come on my
balcony because i don't want this guy in
my house and then i i like respectfully
like you know told him you guys have to
leave we're going to bed soon right
because this amazing penthouse in
downtown toronto we do a lot of parties
and stuff after parties all the fun
stuff
and a few days later
this beautiful woman
is hanging out with me
and uh
you know
she she ended up hooking up with uh me
and my buddy she came in my room while i
was sleeping like she was like cuddling
me we just like hooked up right and then
i left and she's hanging on my buddy
after and i'm just thinking like
this poor girl has a boyfriend who
absolutely loves and adores him but the
issue is like that man just not he's not
fulfilling her
needs emotionally or like sex or some
area of her life and it's do you look at
this girl's instagram she literally
looks like the most perfect little angel
[ __ ] there's not a single sign of
prom promiscuous behavior or
anything that would you know spark as a
red flag she just seems like such a nice
person
and so yeah like it's definitely made me
very suspicious
and curious
of
you know women in general because it's
like i i honestly struggle to date
without thinking like okay my
girlfriend's definitely getting
she could be [ __ ] another guy and so
it's made me extremely picky it's made
me extremely extremely picky and you
know a lot of like behaviors that like a
lot of people would say is controlling
but it's like if i'm dating a girl we're
very serious he's like i'll have her
location turned on and even then i'm
thinking uh but i'm not like demanding
it i just like kind of ex like see how
like i'll kind of just mention i'll turn
mine on and then you know if she doesn't
want to turn her location on it's a girl
on the cooking outfit then it's like
we're just not going to date it's just
not going to happen right like in order
for me to date a woman she has to really
go above and beyond to show that you
know she's interested in just seeing me
believe me
yeah i'd agree with that do you think
the girls instagrams
that are more reserved are the
scariest ones or can you tell from a
girl's instagram if she's been ran
through or if she's
like the actually the good girl you just
ask her
you can just ask her usually because uh
i actually i'm extremely good at getting
girls to admit things
uh that they wouldn't really tell people
because like it's a pretty much you just
have to
demonstrate that you're non-judgmental
uh share some of your crazy stories and
you'd be shocked how many women will
just start sharing
all their crazy sexual experiences and
you're like oh interesting right but now
like
i know now i knowledge is power now i
know like
if i should go for it right if i should
pursue that relationship
yeah and you're right what you said on
the show earlier like there's certain
girls you just put in a category of okay
this girl is not a girl you date and
then there's girls that you meet and you
judge and you make an assessment about
them and you're like i like all these
things about her i learned about their
parents and i learned about the way she
was raised and all that helps gives
insight to make a better educated
decision as to whether this make a good
partner or not you know wow that's so
interesting because you'll say you'll
say something like that and you'll
analyze and look at women and be like
okay this is the decision i'm making if
you tell a woman like yeah that's this
is what i did she'll be like how dare
you but it's like women do the same
thing before we probably even meet a guy
will be like okay we know xyz about him
but we're gonna make we're gonna act
like we don't know that so it's very
interesting that you say that yeah well
look at like dating apps like tinder
right women make the decision but like
in a split second just based on your
aesthetic based on these little things
and women they don't tend to qualify a
guy they tend to disqualify a guy so
they're not looking for a reason to
sleep with a guy they're looking for a
reason not to
right
there could be one little thing i had a
girlfriend uh four years ago we were
like both madly in love and you know a
few months in the relationship she told
me that she was hesitant to wanting to
date me because i didn't iron my shirts
and it's so crazy how like a lot of
women will just find little reasons to
not go for a guy
no matter how trivial or stupid they it
might seem right because those criteria
are important to them
because
anyways
shirt
wow
i feel like women
sometimes
they'll have like a whole package but
they'll be like i need to find an ick
and the guy so i can what's i was
telling you it's hypergamy like that's
why they say you can't beat hypergamy
because even like jeff bezos's girl was
trying to fill out leonardo dicaprio in
front of him and stuff like that because
girls always want to know is this guy
the best i can get and they're always
like testing to see basically women are
scary yo are you scary no
i'm not everyone accepts you yeah
everyone is happy
yeah but i i think that's part of like
what it is to understand game is like
you understand these things these
dynamics about humans and how we behave
that way you make better decisions
decisions for yourself
how how long did you study um
like body language it's been an ongoing
thing to this day but i mean since i
started at 20
and
um because i was doing sales at the time
i was doing presentations one-on-ones
all one on sometimes groups
you know between three to nine
presentations a day so every single day
i was meeting with people and i was just
seeing something change and i'm saying
oh my god then i got to the point where
i can control
even their thinking through mirroring
their body and opening them up and
handing them a pin to open up their body
language or turning the chair doing
little things because i understand that
words don't really matter in
conversations
and then i just i basically it became so
routine that i was literally somewhere
else in my thoughts and doing
presentations and controlling everything
and i know what he's going to say and i
know what the response is going to be
and then signing off and then boom and
like it just got so routine for me
and that's actually how i got introduced
to um
because part of part of body language is
you learn about courtship and how people
go about the mating process and that's
when i was learning about um i think vh1
is the pickup artist the show was coming
out and that's kind of when i first
heard about that community
i was never really involved in it but
i've kind of always seen things about it
uh meeting justin's really like
you know opened my eyes to a lot of that
stuff as well but i learned about it
since i was 20 i'm 34. wow about 14
years
and every single day i think i i mean
it's part of
my thinking what's a body language like
tip or whatever that you notice that
other people don't
uh in what situation
um
[Music]
let's do
[Music]
did you notice any body language on the
podcast yeah of course this guy was
extremely i mean we all saw it
everywhere that's obvious
so you have to tell me one that's not as
obvious
um
something that's not as i mean they
would just be micro gestures is what we
would call them just
like where they're smaller but it's just
you know the thing is this as crazy as
as educated as i am in body language you
intrinsically know all these things
so the way you can just uh detect a lie
from somebody is when the words that are
coming out of their mouth don't match
the body language your brain interprets
there's something off
you may not know the answer but you know
he's lying
we study why we make these gestures with
our hands or why we scratch our nose
when we lie and it's just kind of like
we know the same information but we know
where it's coming from and then we also
determine baseline behavior in a person
so we understand what the norm is so
when they go off the norm we are better
at detecting things
right because some
body language is that i that i'll see
like
you know i just think it's interesting
but
i'll always think like a lot of times
they could be doing those body languages
just because they're awkward sure and
that's what we determine baseline
behavior yeah that that makes more sense
like the one um
they would say like if you're crossing
your arms but i'm like sometimes like
you're cold maybe you're cold yeah maybe
you have back problems and that helps
with your back yeah or you're just on
you know you're just nervous or whatever
so what we would look for is you've been
very open and receptive the entire
conversation even since before but if i
were to make a statement saying oh i
think um i don't agree with this and you
say well you know that's interesting and
you start talking to me like this i know
you disagree with me you're like that
sounds very interesting what you're
saying but i know you don't think that
and i know you're saying that because
you're trying to be at even kill so you
know i can do many things to open you
back up yeah
um
so i can keep your brain open again yeah
to listening to me well it's it's just
the way i think um is one of the reasons
i have this is to remember to like keep
open but i like naturally just like i
don't know it's just like a thing yeah
it's good practice even me i do this
purposely to keep myself open yeah even
when this guy's saying some asinine
things i just stay open so my body
doesn't shut off yeah you know purposely
it's hard you want to close off no i
yeah that's the thing is like
oh my gosh sitting like that for i don't
think i could do it yeah
force myself yeah good practice yeah
yeah like motion creates emotion and if
you change your body language it
actually can change your psychology and
your your mental state as well
and so um
yeah i noticed louise's body there's
always very like still and calm
extremely like
grounded too you can just tell he's in
complete control of his like emotional
state mm-hmm
so tell me about the craziest ketchup
cheater moment
my cameraman almost got beat up really
bad
we were at a concert well now we were at
a concert this girl was putting her
boyfriend to a test
and he was there with um
i think one other guy only but then
there was a group of friends that they
met up with
so there was probably like 20 dudes
they all caught my cameraman filming and
then they're talking and the girl gia
that was hitting on him you know they're
talking and then i see one of the
friends is like looking and then he
whispers and the friend's ears like yo
they're recording you
you know
and then like he's talking to the girl
gee and he's hearing his friend he's
like what's he talking about and then
they all looked over
and my cameraman is just like he's still
staring at the lens you know at this
monitor and he just i see his eyes go
like this
like they're all walking towards him he
doesn't know what to do and there's like
a mob coming towards them and these are
like big guys they're not like small
frail dude they're big dudes i've done
martial arts my whole life it's like
we're gonna we're gonna get we're gonna
get [ __ ] up man like i'm sorry bro
like this is it
you know but uh nothing nothing ended up
happening but that was like in that
moment i'm like they're gonna break our
[ __ ] they're going to figure it out but
they still didn't figure out what was
happening
they did it
what what happened what'd they say to
you um are you filming me dog there's
like some guys from long beach
and then we're like oh yeah no we're
filming some prank video bro it's we're
filming you guys people behind you and
you know things like that oh let me see
the footage and it's like no dude we're
still filming we're still doing like
and then eventually the other guys
calmed them down but like we were
circled
and i was just thinking oh [ __ ] man
but you have that calm vibe so yeah and
i think body language helps in those
scenarios yeah just remaining because
have you ever been in a car with
somebody
while you're driving you're like oh god
and it gives you anxiety yeah so
you're gonna exude that energy to
someone so if someone comes up being
real hard-faced and you just remain calm
it almost like you can control the
energy of the other person
so you know whatever energy you want
them to have you can project and it'll
kind of mirror the same thing when
training animals and stuff like that why
don't you think more people adapt that
type of mentality of knowing like if i
control my emotions
then i know that
it will essentially control the
environment
um
why don't more people do it that's a
great question i think they should i
think if this was a course if i think
everyone should do sales coming out of
school at least for a year i agree i
think even if you don't decide to pursue
it the rest of your life just one year
of doing sales will dramatically change
your life
for the long run for in so many ways
you're going to learn to control your
emotions learn to deal with people like
this and control the conversations and
just learn so much about yourself and
how to handle your own emotions because
i've sat with people that literally
would say you know they're staring at me
and they go i think you're a piece of
[ __ ]
they say yeah i understand uh so on this
next point i'm going to talk about and
like i just keep going like it means
nothing to me they're little sound bites
that they give off because they're
dealing with issues and it means
absolutely [ __ ] all to me
you know and i just always remain calm
and assertive and do my thing and i can
for the most part always get the outcome
i want
interesting do you hate sales
i
i don't like sales i feel like i've been
in the realm not like specifically sales
but there's just something about it that
makes me just like
eerie that i wouldn't go into it but
i've had like little snippets of it
throughout my life with jobs that i've
done yeah yeah i hated it i did it for
two years yeah i hated it too everyone
hates it when they start it's hard
you're dealing with so much in here i
never got good i just quit
i wanted to quit i quit i quit it
started i still i'd quit i moved home
and said dad i'm gonna be a tick-tocker
i did youtube but like
he was ecstatic he was like great job
pearl i didn't know exactly what i
wanted i didn't even tell him i was
moving home i literally i lived like two
hours away in a different city and i
just i had one video go viral on tik tok
it got like four million views and it
had nothing to do with red pill it was
it was just a random story i told and
yeah i literally just quit my job move
my stuff and like showed up at my
parents house i was like yeah i'm i'm
moving home
can i ask you what you think the
solution is to a lot of the problems you
were mentioning earlier which one
i like what do you think the solution is
if you ran society if you were the
president if you had control of the
media oh um
i think a lot of problems started with
the development of birth control i don't
know what i would do now in 2022 because
i don't see birth control going away but
i think a lot of problems would go away
if it was gone
we should just make women have their
body accounts on their forehead
kind of like black mirror
no no andrew tate made a clip about that
went viral about the women on the
forward what do you think of that clip
by the way because we commented on this
we talked about this for like 30 minutes
oh i think it's true
i think yeah i agree now for any girl
listening before you get too jumpy
the interesting thing is that the
comment was i think if every woman had
their body count attached their forehead
a lot of the world's problems would be
solved
right because then we would know the
truth and i would even say in the
reverse i think if girls if every guy
had his net worth his dick size
if he's ever cheated on past
relationships tattooed on his forehead
and women were able to see that that
would also make the world a better place
because now the truth is out there as
opposed to everyone having to lie and
hide
and to one up on on a relationship or
whatnot
and i agree because i mean we're talking
about this it's like look imagine you
see a beautiful girl walking down the
street and she has like a one on her
forehead and you're thinking oh my god
like
she by definition is valuable because
there's less girls like her
right so
it's scarcity right human beings value
scarcity over everything that's why gold
is valuable that's why bitcoin is
valuable right that's why having a nice
car like i don't know a lamborghini
makes you a higher because there's less
of them yeah mm-hmm
i think that'd be beneficial if females
had their body count attached to their
forehead because essentially
they would be more
careful
about who they allow in their life yeah
i'm building that body count because you
have a like pearl posted this video the
other day on her story and this girl had
over 2 000 bodies and i'm like how did
porn star i i don't know who she was
she was something and she's like yeah
she was just casually saying yeah i
probably have over 2 000 bodies from
when i started to have sex up until now
how old is she um i think she's like 27
something like that in her 20s like mid
late 20s do the math on that yeah i'm
trying to do the math right now that's
she said she started at 12. i don't know
like if it was like a good start at 12
or a bad started
we should introduce you to this guy
they'd probably get along
match made in heaven
it sounds messed up but imagine if every
guy you met his actual net worth is on
his forehead so he couldn't lie you know
how many girls he's been with or you
know whether he's cheated in the past
then you can make an educated decision
to say hey look
okay i'll hook up with him or something
or you know this is a guy on a date but
like at least you know the truth yeah up
front i just hate
that it's it's more
i guess you could say qualifications for
a man to be presentable
and
not as many for women like if there was
a thing to have on the forehead it would
just be body count for women but men
have to have xyz i used to think that
was a bad thing but the older i get the
more experience i get the more i realize
it's actually a good thing because with
women in general
they're being competitive over the
highest value men
and in order to adhere to that you have
to be well dressed you know be beautiful
keep yourself nutritionally disciplined
really like work on your
aesthetic and your like femininity right
because a man who's extremely successful
is not gonna settle down with some
unattractive
you know
obese
you know manipulative abusive woman
right but in this by the same metric
for men to date the most beautiful women
they need to be really competitive with
other men and so the crazy thing is like
yes you do need to
make better money uh work on yourself
develop your personality and again i've
been a pickup artist and a dating coach
for 10 years now and i've seen what
women are completely attracted to it's
not money it's not the guy's looks it's
the way the guy makes the woman feel
it's all about her it's all about her
feelings and
the way you can make her feel can be
influenced by so many different things
and a man who makes a lot of money or a
man who drives his car you're making her
feel good emotions you're making her
feel security emotional security
financial security you're making her
feel all these positive things and if
you want beautiful women if you want to
have an amazing dating life sex life
which is amazing life in general with
beautiful women around you you need to
be competitive as a man you need to be a
man of value otherwise you know you're
not selling anything there's no value
there right and so i don't think it's
actually a bad thing that because i used
to think it was a horrible thing i used
to think how great would it be if we
lived in a society where you know women
just want to have sex all the time and
it's super easy even all the women are
like [ __ ] and whatnot and i used to
think that was actually going to be a
really good thing and then hot roll
summer became a thing
and like female rat the rise of female
rap music kind of brainwashing young
women everywhere became more popular and
i actually realized how detrimental that
was to society and like we see society
degrading from our own eyes we can see
you know
women in general have higher body counts
now there's more promiscuity now it's
easier to get laid as a guy but then
you've got guys out there who are
meeting beautiful women and getting laid
when they don't deserve to
yeah
i agree with that they don't deserve to
yeah what do you what do you mean they
don't deserve to
they haven't really earned it it's just
they're just like good looking or
something no it's it's more so that the
women's in an experimental phase in her
life she's going through a breakup she's
trying to have a hot girl summer she's
trying to almost like fit into this like
new narrative
of what is normal and in in doing so
she's gonna hook up a lot of guys and
then there's guys out there who aren't
like sex-worthy men who'll end up you
know getting more sexual experience
right
and it's
it's lowering the quality
of the woman because again you know men
desire things that are scarce like
i think definitely any man who considers
himself a high-value man and wants to
settle down with women long-term maybe
even have a family and things like that
you don't want to think that your your
girlfriend or your long-term partner
slept with you know 50 dudes instead of
you know five mm-hmm right
that's uh that's a huge problem right i
was dating a girl earlier this year and
she told me her body count was between
50 and 100.
yeah and i had no idea i had no idea
before i was seeing her we just kind of
met at a party we hit it off we spent
three days together and it was it was a
huge mistake because by by the end of
the three days i was already like
falling in love with her she turns out
she knew a ton of my friends turns out
she had hooked up with some of my
friends wow it turns out that she had
hooked up with like multiple guys in my
soul circle at one point i counted that
there were seven different men in my
circle that this woman had hooked up
with but we i'd already agreed to
relation dynamic she's if she's telling
me she had to between 500 men it's
probably closer to 100
and i knew from the very get-go it's not
going to work out right
and you shouldn't judge
bruh 50
50.
her body her choice her body her choice
no no like it's cool they can't do that
but it's like they can't be surprised
when the guy is reacting to that
like you it's like how can you be
surprised like this girl was delusional
when she was like oh they shouldn't
judge you shouldn't just like
well i just don't like it when they tell
okay because i have five brothers and
i'm sorry like
it'll be a snowball's chance in hell
before i tell my brother to wife a hoe
i'm sorry no yeah no no no no no you
want
you you want your brothers no
no
no that's like with the whole basketball
team football it's like i'm gonna tell
my brother's like yo she a hoe why are
you sending her back send her back to
the streets my brother is drop her off
at the freeway yo my brother is
entertaining one right now and i'm like
yo like bruh just stop she go hoe cause
she's like oh
i don't do this i don't do that but
she'll talk about dudes that want to
have sex with her xyz and i'm like bro
she's a hoe she's worth the stress send
her back to the streets where she
belongs
exactly first to class ticket economy
you know what's funny my brother is
probably going to marry the manosphere
ideal and he'd like to even i mean mine
is she's not a virgin but she's she was
never out there like that and he didn't
even try this girl went to she's an
engineer she went to culinary school
just for fun now she like cooks for him
cleans for him she does everything wow
and that's just like normal that was
normal 20 years he didn't yeah he didn't
even ask for it she just like like i'm
like oh do you like that he's like
austin keep playing like that's great
keep playing
but it's like
i don't know i just feel like some stuff
is just common sense
i know like we all intuitively know it
right but we've been brainwashed like
society has been completely brainwashed
by tick tock and social media yeah right
it's like when i lost my virginity the
girl awesome he was also a virgin my
first like three or four girlfriends
were virgins right and so yeah like
because i had a great like when i was a
teenager all the girls i was hooking up
with and dating were
virgin women
right and i think the issue is like as
you get older
men and women you get older right and
you know your dating partners now are
not going to be young virgins they're
going to be probably similar age range
right and i think that's also why men
desire younger women they want women
with less emotional baggage
that haven't you know been ran through
right like i'm 27 the girl i'm dating
right now is 20 years old she's only
been a handful of like three guys before
me right because in my head i'm thinking
like that's awesome he's like i live in
toronto and he's streaming
and even if she's lying what is it like
seven
she would have started a year three
justin yeah
no but the thing is so again i live in
toronto there's a huge sugar baby
culture yeah uh only fans girls
everywhere like i have this huge circle
of only fans girls sugar baby girls
we're friends but like i don't i don't
hook up with them i i don't want to
right and i could but i just choose not
i try not to right i don't i don't think
it's even like
because i don't want to be around that
kind of energy right
and the thing is
you know
women who are have more innocence
impurity to them are going to be easier
to be around
you know
so i have a question do you find
that younger women have less bodies
because this is the the like flip of it
and i i do understand like so i'll talk
to people i you know all the time and
i'll say like they like younger women
last but like the whole the whole red
pill but then the the counter argument i
hear is like well these girls are are
wild and even more than we ever did and
i do think there's some truth to that do
you what do you think like
like your business is to hook up with
girls do you think that the younger
women are looser than the older women i
think it depends on what city you are in
the world okay uh what type of woman
you're talking to because you can meet
entirely different types of women in the
same city depending on what venues you
go to what circles you're hanging around
but like if you're doing day game
picking up girls in in the daytime
you're gonna meet women who are
extremely conservative right like you
can go to um
a university campus and just go like
talk to girls right or like uh hang
around like places where you're gonna
meet you know
more wholesome women and then you go to
nightclub the girls in the nightclub are
definitely more promiscuous than the
girls that you meet in the library right
right and so it depends where you're
meeting these types of women right so
like as a dating coach i usually
recommend my clients if you want to meet
a girlfriend you want me to during the
day go to the park right right go walk
your dog and like bump into a girl and
then just start up a conversation you
start dating her right what do you what
do you think about um church girls
because the only virgins that like the
girls that i know that waited till they
were married to have sex i've only met
in the church but at the same time i do
i do think the church makes hoes so i
don't even know what to like i don't
know what to think of it my family's
catholic i grew up catholic yeah and i
went to church twice a week for like 15
years straight
and i i'd definitely say that yeah sure
the church girls are going to be more
wholesome but they're going to be
virgins until you're married and unless
you want to wait for that it's just like
i don't think it's even an ideal dating
partner either unless you truly truly
desire a virgin
wife right
and
the other factor is like the guys who
you're probably gonna be able to get
that girl she's gonna have
too much like mental complications for
you to even be able to get her right you
really have to know what you're doing
and
like unless you're going to church to
pick up chicks like it's just you're not
meeting that kind of girl was your
ex-girlfriend religious
uh she was raised religious yeah okay
would you say she's
like she's raised jehovah's witness her
sister married her first partner and all
that stuff and okay yeah why didn't you
marry her that's a great question and
like
yeah like you know i would never close
the door because her and i just had a
location thing like she just wasn't
allowed to be in the country i couldn't
go over there covered lockdowns things
like that oh okay kind of kept us
separated and whatnot oh i know you
don't believe in marriage i forgot but
like yes i mean i believe in it because
it exists it's not like something i
desire yeah yeah you know
the wedding actual wedding yeah sure
let's have a party it sounds like fun
yeah you know
but um
yeah
i don't know what was the question oh i
asked like why didn't you marry her
yeah i think it was just it was a very
short notice to make that decision
um because that would be the only way i
should be in the countries if i marry
her and it's like you know we didn't get
to spend enough time together yeah but
um also i think there's there's an age
difference that i think um
will even out as she gets older that's
why i always say like i'll never rule
her out
for the future or nothing like that
but um you know we'll see
wasn't ready for it yeah well i was just
um
because the other thing the red pill
will say is like the problem with
virgins is they get curious
it depends i don't think so this is just
this is just um
i've had this in my comment section
where like a guy will be dating a virgin
but the problem is if she has too many
like hoe friends like they'll then they
get she's nodding yeah i would
definitely
not me personally but i knew someone who
was a virgin and like the
group she was in as all they talked
about was this dude they were hooking up
with that dude they were hooking up with
so she felt like she was missing out and
so when she did lose her virginity she
was like i'm joining the club now i lost
my virginity and it's like
no if you if you kept it this long she
kept it up until like
i would say a few years ago and we're
around the same age and it's like if you
wanted to keep it that long
why did you all of a sudden just oh i
want to lose it when you could have left
lost it a long time ago
no i think like
virgins are the best bet like if i was
my brother like i would want him to
marry a virgin
but
this is just [ __ ] i hear in the
manosphere so i was just curious well so
the thing is
that that concept of like her
girlfriend's talking about talking about
all these guys is that's gonna happen
anyway
virgin or not virgin right yeah but
the thing is like i mean i've honestly
been with a lot of virgin women and
you'd be shocked how even promiscuous
the virgin women are
right because are you sure they're
virgins
yeah so uh are you sure are you really
sure yeah this might be this might be a
little bit personal and like a little
bit like out there but so early this
year after i broke up with that
girlfriend who doing like 1500 guys i
was like no more girlfriends
now like like no more girlfriends
absolutely not i'm just like i'm just
gonna [ __ ] i i said she wanted to
have a harem and over three four months
i just i had like
seven different women i was dating um
all of them were bisexual and they all
knew about each other were all like kind
of like a friend group it was really
interesting it became this like weird
like ecosystem of like uh kind of like a
circle where like it was non-monogamous
where i didn't care if they
date other guys there's no boyfriends
but
the ones that are like i'm like more
serious with the ones who i kind of more
consider my girlfriend like they were
monogamous to me so i had like two maybe
three girls who were like like it was it
was kind of polygamy where
they're they're just seeing me
but um
you know
i see other girls but they're all
friends it is interesting and so there
was one night where i was a wild man i
was having a threesome with two of them
and one of them was a virgin she was
just she was a friend like we never
hooked up i never considered like
hooking up and she just joined she just
she wanted to kind of join in
yeah so she lost virginia
i've been trying to understand the
dynamics since that night because me and
this girl didn't really talk much she
would call my parties sit on my table
i'll kind of just ignore her like we we
didn't really have any much of a
relationship other than the fact that uh
you know her friends were out with me
but it's just like when you're in that
kind of social dynamic where you know
i'm the cool party guy we're in the club
stuff every single weekend friday
saturday night and we always in the back
of my house she sees me with different
girls it's like she automatically is
going to categorize me
as this
you know high value guy she potentially
wouldn't want to hook up with and i'm
like i'm not even thinking about that
i'm not thinking like i'm just i have to
hook up these girls i'm just thinking
like i don't want a girlfriend i'm going
to hook up lots of girls i want to be
around people are not judging me and i
didn't want to feel like judge or shame
for wanting to hook up lots of girls
right and so that's why i was
specifically only dating bisexual girls
and even letting them be open like do
whatever they want as long as you know
they come back to me and then the
the girls were like kind of like my
girlfriends you know obviously they're
kind of we just see each other
exclusively and what was really
interesting is how this girl was just
instantly sees me two other girls
instantly down just loose virginia being
experimental
and then the next time we're hanging out
uh i was you because you're with me he
was visiting toronto uh then in june
and uh we're hanging out and she kept
talking about how hot louise is and so
now she church like we hooked up and now
she's like she wants to go through her
whole face and she wants to like hook up
with lots of guys and so luis didn't
want to hook up with her but then so she
went from like want to hook up me to
louise to like
another dude some dorky nerd that she
perceived to have value just because
hanging out with us but i mean that guy
was total nerd right
and i just thought it was really
interesting how there's a lot of virgin
women who will lose virginia and just go
complete other than the spectrum and
completely like want to be degenerate
party hot girl summer
it's just they took them a while to be
ready and now they just want to you know
hook up with guys like pandora's box
exactly it's it's
it's open and now
you know i i haven't even talked to her
since that weekend actually you're in
toronto i have so many questions for you
sure how how was that having like your
own i guess you could say ecosystem with
those women stressful really i started
breaking out pimples because like it's
crazy whereas uh
it's almost like dating a bunch of girls
at the same time if one girl is upset
they all get upset so you kind of gotta
like keep the peace among all them and
uh you know like making sure everyone
has a place to sleep because so i live
in a two-bedroom penthouse but again
it's like downtown toronto real estate's
expensive there's not place where i want
to sleep right there's like two or three
girls in the bed you know two girls on
the couch one girl in like the little uh
you know chair sometimes i have i'd have
a girl sleep on my balcony my two girls
sleeping in the car in the parking
garage it was and i remember you were in
toronto visiting me that weekend and we
wake up there's just like seven girls
slept over that night and it was just
like it's i almost felt like i was like
a dad you know like taking care of
people to like make sure everyone's fed
after the club get like party pizzas and
stuff like that
and uh
i i decided that i actually i came to
like
i came from a very traditional family my
parents are still married after 30 years
right
and
like deep down no matter like how many
breakups i've gone through i've been in
love nine times okay
wow so
i even after that relationship dammit
with all these women i decided
it wasn't worth the stress because i i
stopped my business at the time i just
wasn't working i was just dating right
because it takes up so much time and
energy
and resources
and like mental energy and it's
stressful so i decided i'd rather have
just one girlfriend yeah than all these
girls
how how old are you again 27.
you've lived uh yes
definitely interesting is it because of
the industry you're in do do you
do you have more i want to say time to
date then like more than definitely yeah
yeah because this is my life it's like i
said nine times
dating is a tax write-off and market
research for me so
it's like it's just an excuse if that
was a tax write-off for me i'd go on
dates all the time
like alcohol wine like
it's i'm not making this up because i
mean i can
as long as i can justify and then it's
like it's not a waste of time right
because i'm always learning and i've
been doing this for 10 years and like
when i say dating i used to turn very
loosely i'm talking about like partying
hugging the girls having fun
but i also so i don't drink alcohol so
that way i'm always remembering
everything and i'm like always in
control and it's always like a learning
experience right because i also don't
want to go down the degenerate route of
just hooking up all the time so there's
even like times where i go like kind of
relatively celibate where i try to like
abstain from just like hook up culture
because i also don't think that's
healthy it becomes like a addiction of
like emotional validation yeah
[Music]
wow
how many how many women did you have at
once in your ecosystem
it's kind of hard to quantify that
because what does that mean right so i
would say like about if i if i'm looking
like very loosely about a dozen that's
girls i'm not sleeping with yet or girls
i'm like i just hooked up with once and
they still come out with me um but i
remember there was a party i had uh
against the same weekend here in toronto
where i looked at my because
because every week i get paid by clubs
to show up and have pretty girls around
me and i counted nine or ten girls in
the same room that i've had sex with
right
and it's it's very common i'll go out
and i'll be in a room and there's like
five to ten girls in one room that i've
hooked up with even like a couple weeks
ago do you guys ever like hook up with
the same girls
luis not typically do you have different
types
i like good girls
i've also kind of like exited my way out
of the hook-up culture i'm a little bit
older than justin i'm 34 now so i kind
of feel like i've been there done that
and um
not that i would be opposed to it it
feels like someone i really was
interested in but really like i said
this is justin i say this to some of his
students when i talk to them because a
lot of them come up to me privately and
they'll talk to me about things and i'll
say you know man when i'm with a girl
even if she's pretty
it's like
nothing changes if we have like some one
night stand i don't wake up tomorrow
nothing like nothing's changed so if we
have sex nothing's changed if we don't
have sex nothing's changed so i
genuinely enjoy getting to know a girl
or learning about her and seeing what
kind of girl she is and like i also feel
that you know you i don't want to
attract certain energies into my life
so i get to sit there and actually
qualify and make sure that there's a
girl i'd want to spend time with or be
with or be in a relationship with
qualify it's like a sales term yeah i
want to qualify yeah because i ask
questions i'm learning about her
behavior i'm learning about the [ __ ]
clubs every week and what is she doing
and then i'm like okay luis like is this
someone you want to spend time with
especially since i've raised a lot of my
my other end of my back end of my who i
am as a person
i have to be more cautious of the
decisions i make and the partners i
select because there's a lot more to
risk now when i was younger i was a
degenerate and like whatever so and you
said you just retired right
have you retired is that from like the
the youtube channel how to catch a
cheater just in general
everything okay
no i meant like was that your main
career the how to catch a cheater no i
stopped to catch a cheater like a year
and a half two years ago oh [ __ ] i
started another i started a kid's
channel and uh i was doing that okay
yeah well i was just asking how you're
able to retire at 35 like 34 but uh
before
don't age him like i'll probably get
back to work because what else am i
going to do yeah and i'm happy so i'm
following my purpose but
um right now i think i'm enjoying just
mental clarity of having
no responsibility
having no
you know like every time i'd even try to
vacation i'm working yeah i'd always
have work on my mind if i wasn't working
physically i'm working in my mind but
what what is work that's what i'm asking
is that youtube
just everything i buy so
youtube leads to residuals sponsors but
then i save all my money i'm you know i
drive a ford fusion
i'm not like i only like two months ago
i bought these jewelry but i'm like i'm
really not materialistic at all okay so
yeah at all i buy properties i got four
rentals okay okay um
you know i airbnb them all out so even
that's an additional income
i have my expenses low i have zero debt
whatsoever like not even close right and
then i have a lot of money saved still
on top of that so i'm hoping a recession
happens i buy even more property and
okay kick some families out of their
house yeah
you kids ow
it's mine
no my parents do airbnb so i'm i'm
familiar that's a good business i just
wasn't sure if like um youtube was your
main thing it was something it was like
90 95 of my income and it wasn't the how
to catch a cheater that was you to catch
cheater first but then from there i
moved over to life lessons with louise
got it okay but before that it was the
properties um before that i actually had
airbnbs okay i actually ran a course
also on udemy teaching how to do airbnb
got it before that i had a gift card
business before that i was doing network
marketing for five years
um
i've never had like a job
outside of working for my dad when i was
in middle school i had to go poor
concrete with them
but um
and how did you guys get familiar with
red pill how did you find my channel
actually so my buddy david bond actually
posted your tick tock
in a
telegram group and in this group is
really interesting because in the group
was one of my friends who's a
billionaire uh one of my friends who's
uh another dating coach
there's like 29 people in it so it's a
bunch like crypto millionaires
dating coach youtubers and just a bunch
of like very eccentric people and all of
them are very like
centered towards like you know a lot of
philosophies you talk about because
we're all dating and very actively
dating very interesting lifestyles and
david uh also had a well so where i got
the whole harem concept was from him
because he was living in colombia and he
literally had 20 girlfriends and his
thing was very structured he had like he
had a rule book like it was extreme like
it was like a club it was like an
official thing
and
you know
a lot of the concepts that you talk
about
are so universal
but only relate to high value men and i
feel like the reason your your stuff's
really blown up is because it's so
relatable to life of
any guy from very average mediocre
dating life or any guy who's been
married or any guy who's got a
girlfriend she's like we can all relate
to it
and
yeah so i came across your tick tock and
i was just obsessed i was just binge
watching it i was like this is amazing
right because i i couldn't believe that
there is a woman talking about red pill
and
it's such a struggle for most guys to
realize that right and i think most guys
get red pilled once they've had enough
experience with women uh that's how i
came across you oh okay and i share with
louise share with my sister share with
all my girlfriends you know i'm like
okay i i ca we can have multiple
okay i was just curious because um
people kind of find it and some people
get mad when they find it it's awesome
do you label yourself as a red pill
person
um
yeah i would say overall um i would say
i lean a little bit into conservative
just because um i don't know if you
probably i don't think i told this story
um i repeat stories a lot so i have to
like remember but i'm pretty pro-life
because my mom got pregnant when she was
17 and she gave that kid up for adoption
and we like reunited with him later and
then like they adopted three kids so i'm
like i would say because of that i don't
think that's red pill like that's more
conservative but i would say a little
mixable
interesting
yeah
um
well i think that's all my questions i
have for you guys i feel like i've been
grilling you no it's all good i also
want to say that like i feel like we're
talking about virginity and all this i
don't want to reduce a woman's value to
just her sexual
you know numbers because there's a lot
more to a girl than just that but like
you know if we're speaking like
logistically or what makes for a good
bet on a partner
like yeah but it's like almost at the
back of my mind when i'm talking to
girls it's not like it's something yeah
you know what i mean well it matters and
that's the thing is i i don't like how
society that that's what pisses me off
is i don't like lying to younger women
and acting like it doesn't matter
because it does
and if you are still a virgin like you
should protect that and i don't i don't
like older women like lying to younger
women to like compete with them i don't
think that's like some throwaway item a
lot of older women absolutely lie to
young women
right and they're trying to promote
promiscuity
because again women are competitive if
you're pa you're competing over the same
men right there's only limited men and
women like sure we have eight billion
people in the world but you can if you
live in a city let's say like average 30
million people like there's only so many
high-value single men in that city right
and so yeah you're competing over the
same men yeah and uh i mean we're
talking about this earlier do you
remember when we were we're at dinner
and uh luis was joking because like
there's this very common thing you hear
where because again i'm 27 i know tons
of women are 27 and they'll always say
the same thing oh you only like 20 year
old women because they're easy to
manipulate or and what was what was your
response to that oh yeah because they go
oh you just like younger girls because
you can control them and it's like i can
control older women too if i want like
it's the same thing it's what's the
difference the only difference is
i think a younger girl there's more
ability for you to leave an imprint on
the way she's gonna her philosophies in
life and whatnot as opposed to a girl
who's already been through a bunch of
different guys who have imprinted on her
already and now i'm having to
come into a relationship and have a lot
more i guess baggage or old philosophies
that aren't serving her adapt to my
lifestyle um it's just not going to
match as much
but you know predominantly like i used
to make fun of this all the time we talk
about girls that get together they're
like older they get together at like
applebee's on a wednesday night
they sit around and talk about how men
ain't [ __ ] you know they're just all
angry and bitter and stuff like that
and i think um
if a girl hasn't taken care of herself
mentally and emotionally as she ages
they tend to become bitter towards men
like a little bit angry and a younger
girl is a little bit more fun and bubbly
hasn't really experienced all that stuff
so i just i i keep going back to like
you know where does she live emotionally
where did she live mentally
yeah i think we naturally are inclined
to want younger girl younger women but
like no it's not everything
but it matters yeah no it does i agree
um well do you want to tell the people
where they can find you sure yeah you
guys can find me on instagram my
instagram is drunkjustin2
uh my youtube channel justin mark i also
have a podcast called the wingman
podcast
it's uh on spotify
apple or on youtube so you search with
the wingman pocket or wingmanpodcast.com
you can find us there
cool i'm on uh
instagram at real luis mercado any of my
links for anything else you can pretty
much find right after uh clicking there
jess what's your instagram she's got a
new one a new username yeah my new
username is your girl jess least a lot
less complicated than the last one yeah
we had to we had to get ready i changed
it i think it's a good one i i like it i
like the new one simple
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
to the channel like the video on your
way out
um you already know if you've watched
two or more of our lives and you don't
subscribe so if you watch the one
earlier that's two okay that is two we
have beef
like the video on your way out and we
will talk to you next time
bye see you guys